It's Tuesday. It is time for "WeTweet." Here we go.
-♪ WeTweet ♪
♪♪
♪ WeTweet ♪
-Welcome to "WeTweet."
This is where we, as a group,
decide something we should post on Twitter.
So, I'm going to show you five different tweets.
We're all going to vote
on whether you like each one or not, okay?
You all have your voting clickers at your seats?
Higgins, Roots, you have clickers?
-Yep, got my clicker.
-Now, look, now, whatever tweet gets the most likes,
we will tweet it out live on the show.
And then you can all like it and WeTweet it.
-Nice!
-It's a shared experience. All right. Here you go.
So you got the green and red on the clicker here.
And vote for all of them, just so you know,
'cause some people wait to save their vote.
Doesn't matter. Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
You can vote for all of them if you want.
-Yeah, if you love all of them, great. Yeah.
-All right, here we go.
This first one says...
So cast your votes. There we go.
Everyone, cast -- Yep. Very good. I see.
All right. Here we go.
Let's see. The votes are in. Let's see the results.
-Oh.
-Oh, that got a nice response.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Okay. Here we go. That's not bad.
-No. Pretty darn good. -Yeah, that's not bad.
Alright. Here we go. -Underpants.
-Thank you. Yeah, I like this.
This next one goes...
[ Laughs ]
-I like that one.
-I like that one. No one's gonna vote for it.
I think it's pretty good. No, I can already feel --
-You have a feeling it's not gonna go good.
-I can already feel that no one's gonna vote for this one.
But let's see. Let's see the results.
-Oh! -Oh. Not bad.
That's okay. It's okay.
-The other one -- Underpants is still in the lead.
-Alright. This is tweet number three.
It says...
[ Laughter ]
Is that too -- Is it too real?
-Yeah. Yeah, that's more of like a fact.
-More of a fact? -Yeah.
-Yeah. Alright. I like it.
Alright. Let's see the results.
-Oh, wow!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's a slam dunk. -Wow.
-Again -- How come you guys didn't clap or you didn't --
It was like you faked me out there.
You got poker face.
They almost kept quiet, like, on purpose.
They're like, "No, we're not sure if we like it."
And then loved it.
Very, very interesting.
-That's stealth.
-Here we go. Tweet number four.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I understand.
I understand. But how did you figure it out?
Uh, alright. I think this is gonna do pretty well.
Let's see the results on this one.
Nice. -Whoa!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-189. Come on! -That's almost a perfect score.
-Yeah.
-Almost the highest score one can get.
-Yeah, that's it. -189.
-This is the last one here. This says...
Alright. Cast your votes right there.
I already know which one it is.
I'm gonna say...
Alright. Ready? And let's see the results.
-Ooh!
-Dead heat! -Wow.
-That's kind of rare, as well. I love it.
Alright. Looks like the winner is...
[ Bell dinging ]
I'm going to post this during commercial break.
Thank you for helping out. If you see it on your feed,
give it a like, give it a WeTweet, and enjoy.